et
[Musique]
sera protégé par 588 employés municipaux
compétents disponibles et créatif
l'autre je présente à gilbert la merde
je suis le nouveau jeu vous dérange vous
pêchez peut-être là je pense pas je
travaille je me consacre vont organiser
le planning offre me concentre sur le
planning je me concentre un peu loupé
c'est le planning des effectifs les fils
rouges
j'ai des collègues qui sauve sa longue
durée fichaux orages
les absents moyenne durée et puis je ne
sais pas encore pour quelle durée
et puis leur fiche verte tous ceux qui
bossaient avec ce visage là aussi
machine pas
port vendres est un exemple de modernité
tu as un iphone ou un iphone un iphone
tu fais photos vers le haut un iphone le
tuer des photos horizontale ah d'accord
s'il y avait une coupe d'europe des
villes les mieux équipées on sera en
showcase ligue chasse-neige haïtiano
neige mais il n'est jamais un port
vendres mais monsieur le maire la
situation est catastrophique trop
d'équipés trop de personnel trop de
véhicules deux attaquants les poids
lourds et tu l'as 17 mai au 19 mai je
prends deux jours de rtt ce qui fait que
quand j'arrive au lundi de la compote et
je reprends le travail mardi j'ai pris
deux jours et j'en ai eu 11 22 millions
d'euros de déficit lennar comme une
solution là je vous préviens g vous
couper les vivres aux réductions
budgétaires
c'est que midi à new york bret les murs
des mecs qui a fait l'ena qui a une
longueur 6 ans maintenant il faut pas
lâcher
ils vont craquer apprécié de paris harry
centre centre je veux de la finesse un
jeu du surge ical ghislaine et six deux
corées plaisir c mip etienne grève c'est
parti
qui est pour que ça retombe sur le
service des eaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a de nouveau à ces dates ouais là
j'ai appris à déposer les retraités
passent assez pour tenir t il sera de
pagodes impression qu on a même eu tant
que tu y es pas que tu peux pas te
rendre compte
[Musique]